CNN is reporting
Joe Biden is not actually running for
re-election CNN reports that top
Democrats and donors have reached out to
quote possible replacements for Joe
Biden and had conversations about them
getting in the race as Joe Biden
struggles for the White House what does
this mean top Democrats and the media
and the liberal establishment do not
want Biden to run the reason that they
don't want him to run for reelection is
because right now he's probably going to
lose that means that contrary to what
you've been hearing from a lot of the
media reports that there's no way that
Donald Trump could ever possibly beat
Joe Biden the liberal media clearly
think that Donald Trump could beat Joe
Biden because right now Donald Trump is
overwhelmingly likely to get the GOP
nomination so if they felt that Biden
could beat Trump walk away with it then
they would make Biden the nominee and
then he would quietly go off into the
sunset after he won re-election